[Music]
not about the time you're having
straight from tour to comic-con and
inspire yes are you having a pinch me
moment right now I mean you're always
doing great thing I know thank you so
much I definitely a.m. I feel like I
always am I I feel so lucky to be able
to do what I love and to get off stage
and run to Flynn get on it come here and
do this for two films it's really
amazing and then we're back on the road
tomorrow so it's all very surreal who
are you
do you speak poner so we have a female
lead Transformers film we're going to
the 80s I mean what does that mean to
you first of all to have this role and
and how did you get into the 80s mindset
well I mean it means a great deal to me
to be able to play a young female
heroine and she's incredible this
character Charlie Watson and Bumblebee
she really takes being a typical sort of
misunderstood teenager to the next level
in terms of fighting for her voice and
her freedom and it's amazing and getting
into the might eighties mindset was was
really a blast just on all fronts kind
of immersing myself in that world
through the music and the hair and the
makeup in the wardrobe that's always
that's always the fun part it looks so
fun it is weird having a comic-con
without your barely lethal sister sophie
turner but how excited are you for her
engagement what are you expecting from
i'm milky i am so excited for her enjo
they're both great friends of mine and
Sophie's my sister so I love her and
anything that makes her happy
what do you have coming up on her LP
well you know it's so it's crazy I
little busy you know little busy I
planned on putting an album out in the
fall but obviously here at comic-con
I've got fun will be coming out
and to the spider-verse I have a show
Dickinson that I'm shooting after tour
so I'll have singles coming out but
taking my time with the album making
sure it's right so you know
[Music]